Cut her bindings. I want her to be able to
pray on her knees.
For God's sake, Serena.
And. Wait wait wait wait wait.
You got to let me do it. I need to do it.
Okay. Yes. She killed my husband. She cursed
my child. I should do it.
God is giving me a chance for justice. I need
to do it.
Give me the gun. Let me do it.
Serena.
Don't do it. Pray.
Okay. Okay.
I pray for our children. I pray.
That my daughters. Live a life of peace.
A life without all of this hate.
And violence.
Give them a life.
Give them a happy life. Dear God.
May they do better than we did. Amen.
Oh.
Are. Oh.
Oh. No!
Ha! Ha!
Get in the car. What are you doing?
Get in the car.
Go!
Serena, what the fuck are you doing?
Daria. Get in the car.
Oh! Hurry up!
Drive.
Serena, what the fuck are you doing? Just
drive.